>> Laura: AS I MENTIONED IN
THE AN GEL, CONSERVATIVE
SPEECH IS UNDER ASSAULT.
AND ONE OF THE STARKEST
EXAMPLES IS THAT MARQUETTE
UNIVERSITY IS A PRIVATE
CATHOLIC SCHOOL IN
MILWAUKEE.
POLITICAL SCIENCE PROFESSOR
JOHN McADAMS WAS SUSPENDED
AND HAS BEEN SINCE 2014 WHEN
HE CHASTISED A GRADUATE
INSTRUCTOR NAMED CHERYL
ABBOTT E.
WHY SHE TOLD A STUDENT SHE
WOULD NOT TOLERATE DISSENT
ON THE TOPIC OF SAME SEX
MARRIAGE ON THE CLASS ON
ETHICS.
LEGAL TRITE SUSPEND HIM
BECAUSE HE OPENED HER UP TO
THREATS BY CRITICIZING HER
BY NAME.
THE CASE IS NOW HEADED TO
WISCONSIN SUPREME COURT.
JOINING US NOW TO EXPLAIN
FURTHER IS PROFESSOR
MCADAMS HIMSELF.
PROFESSOR, YOU HAVE TAUGHT
FOR 30 YEARS AT MARQUETTE.
AND AS A CATHOLIC
INSTITUTION AND, YET, THIN
STRUCTURE BERATED A STUDENT
WHO SAID BASICALLY NOT ALL
OF US AGREE ON YOUR VIEW ON
SAME SEX MARRIAGE.
TELL US.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
IT SEEMED EYE ROPE NIC
BECAUSE MARQUETTE CLAIMS TO
BE A CATHOLIC INSTITUTION.
A LOT OF YOUR VIEWERS KNOW A
LOT OF INSTITUTIONS CLAIM TO
BE CATHOLIC BUT THEY ARE
SECULAR AND POLITICALLY
CORRECT.
>> Laura: DIDN'T THEY DEMAND
THAT YOU PROSTRATE YOURSELF
BASICALLY AND APOLOGIZE FOR
THIS SUPPOSED WRONGDOING IN
YOUR BLOG POST WHERE YOU
SAID WE ARE BASICALLY HARDLY
A UNIVERSITY IF THIS IS WHAT
WE ARE LIKE, IF WE DON'T
TOLERATE ANY DISSENT.
AND YOU REFUSED, IS THAT
RIGHT, TO APOLOGIZE, SIR?
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
THEY TOLD ME THAT THEY WOULD
REINSTATE ME IF I APOLOGIZED
AND PROMISED TO CONFORM TO
MARQUETTE'S SUPPOSED GUIDING
VALUES PROMISE TO DO IT.
I THINK I'M MORE LOYAL TO
MARQUETTE'S GUIDING VALUES
THAN THE ADMINISTRATION OF
MARQUETTE UNIVERSITY.
OF COURSE THIS IS STALINIST
STUFF.
I'M NOT GOING TO APOLOGIZE.
>> Laura: 130 YEARS HAVE
PASSED AND UNLESS OUR
RESEARCH IS WRONG, NOT A
SINGLE PROFESSOR HAS LOST
TENURE.
130 YEARS.
BUT, BOY, I GUESS YOU ARE A
BIG THREAT, PROFESSOR.
BECAUSE YOU ACTUALLY DECIDED
TO POST A BLOG.
>> YEAH, IT'S IRONIC,
PROFESSORS HAVE LOST TENURE
BUT IT HAD TO BE SOMETHING
LIKE STEALING MONEY FROM
RESEARCH FUNDS OR RAPING A
STUDENT.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
NO PROFESSOR THAT ANYONE
KNOWS ABOUT HAS EVER BEEN
FIRED OR EVEN SUSPENDED FOR
A BLOG POST.
>> Laura: DO YOU FEEL BAD
ABOUT HURTING THE FEELINGS
OF THIS PARTICULAR STUDENT
INSTRUCTOR?
I GUESS SHE GOT A DEAL ON
HER TUITION?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT SHE GOT
SOME REALLY NASTY EMAILS,
ALTHOUGH SHE HAD GOTTEN NO
THREATS.
MARQUETTE HAS CLAIMED SHE
GOT THREATS.
SHE ADMITTED IN ONE OF HER
OPEN BLOG POSTS THAT SHE HAD
GOTTEN NO THREATS.
THAT WASN'T GOOD.
ON THE OTHER HAND, ANYBODY'S
WHOSE MISCONDUCT REVEALED BY
A JOURNALIST MIGHT GET SOME
UNKIND RESPONSES.
>> Laura: THAT'S FOR SURE,
PROFESSOR.
I HAVE BEEN ON THE RECEIVING
END OF THAT WE WILL FOLLOW
YOUR CASE.
I KNOW THE ARGUE.